hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to tug the table with
wait here hey guys
they really planned that far ahead so I
don't know what come fix uh play a game
I don't zoom right don't bomb I know
Obama you see his haircut Oakley you
will never be a good politician Obama
yeah isn't he like sitting here now or
something
ah you're an Obama well that was funny
let's try this again
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to tug the table yeah
table those two energetic there's no
idea I just got sick of them
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Doug the table with
wait here hey guys welcome back to the
rematch of the sensation my mind I don't
want you to hello everybody my name is
markiplier Oh
so I actually literally had something
going wrong with my throat there hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to the saddest game we
should do like really depressed like
that everyone could relate to it like
immediately after a bad puppy dies or
something like that we're just like okay
the moment click hey guys wanna test
that done we're gonna target table I was
old yeller long to tuck the table hey
why do you have to fold down that mine
shaft they get run over by my car and it
wasn't like a ding ding my chapters
literally weird mine yeah it's so Stu
was still a Guinness face I was late
hello everybody it's the gun on the set
I don't even know if that's gonna be in
there oh yeah some bad is so about to
cry there hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to Doug the
table with Wade here hey guys
in the interest of self-preservation
we're actually gonna start the game
because we don't know what the hell
we're doing it are you wait for the
right let's do this reverence I won last
time and we're gonna be able to play
this again and in it okay you started
ready no you started what is talking and
then you started all over the house just
read here okay
alright we needed roses a very civil and
calm way three go I can't go without you
so I don't know why you were owned whoa
whoa I just don't know made a victory
hump of the air they're bigger than do
thee no well this is gonna be an easy no
man
oh this game yeah screw mole hair really
buff I was the one winning well that's
cuz I wasn't even trying I was just
trying to make you feel good about
yourself I'm the best ever can I'm over
on your side it's exactly how it should
be oh no no no no yeah
no where's this ball cut all the bells
on my side you have some I didn't my big
head pop off oh that's much better that
okay good the louder I screamed the less
it blows everything yes exactly
oddly oh no well no no no okay what
happened I was waiting there for a
little bit no no whatever just go go
what handed yeah call me back call them
back word is Coleman well now I got I
know what side I shoes on the other foot
now no I win I just wanted it to not be
a total washout so I do feel that
terrible about how bad you are at this
game well thank you you're welcome
why are we on there where'd you get a
cab you lose Fanny I drew yeah oh those
every fan girls dream Oh
so as we can see I have now won but
we're going best of five or something
like yeah and he's gonna have a chance
to win again but probably not Africa oh
yeah we'd start over I forgot how to
play this game it's been a while clearly
not you just won I know already did well
they did it they do they wait let's do a
replay of all the times I done yeah
oh I had Jenny from are you baby the
table after jig that you loser and you
know a winner you personally know a
winner cuz I know myself and I art valve
why did you push the ready button if you
weren't around oh no cuz muscle memory
no no continue please what were you
doing I have no idea you were about to
pontificate about how you know i 4i
aren't valve me I don't know what I'm
say you need to press the W before you
do that because I aren't that it was
once Bow Wow and whoa the extremities of
my no your own feet over in lies oh oh
well it's gonna be easy I like it no I
don't like it I like it touching with
your hand in the winter here whoa whoa
whoa don't zoom out whatever you're not
wearing whoa what you know I have pants
on
ah whoa that was like the angriest face
I've ever seen in my own that's the face
of a loser okay okay let's go for a baby
oh my god no no that just proves it
there's there's no skeletons right
another trial okay you look over there
all right
cover your eyes cover your eyes cover
your eyes okay ready here we go
who's ready i won yeah okay next use
don't like an epic comeback all right
come on well no oh you just look sad
down I know I was just hoping back no
turn the table upside down oh no in the
world this game makes no sense
is it I really don't think there's any
skill to this you're just having bad
luck oh good god were you like okay - it
was - to - what it wants to play of all
the balls in my face I don't care if I
got this many balls in my head Halla
ticket all right Oh comes down to this a
final mark final finalist I let you have
it all go lay all no yes yeah yes yeah
just like your face and then you'd uh I
don't know how you got so good at this
button game I don't know either
well I mean you and mol hammers that's
true yeah oh yeah it's a tugboat really
yes I uh
he pulled the tight damn the Titanic did
Zdenek to Tampa tip Tarek lieutenant the
Titanic instead of smoke that's what she
said good job they're so good
watching no no it's still small but they
just look like boobs or it actually
moves you weirdo oh you came out the
sides of it go ahead
oh I'm just lined up opening their
mouths is like you drove on no it's used
fuel you dingus you don't drink they
used milk why not because it's use has
been through the milk engine no one
wants to drink the milk engine milk
don't we all drink milk engine milk no
we don't it comes straight from the cows
with no processing with not cows okay
first of all it's Badgers cat superb and
your milk Hunter the Titanic ran on 100%
pure badger milk
I thought you learned this in history
we were all badger milk oh okay well
come on back me up everybody out there
everyone remembers in vicious if you get
a badge is not good boys be like
spraying badger I mean it's not like the
Badgers have normal human boobs
although yo genetic modification
eventually did lead to badges with human
boobs
it was then like cow udders on there's
like so close to the ground this is like
dry by oh that's how it was it was a
problem the babies just like chasing and
like grabbing their udders are their own
pouch
Oh what is wrong with it I think you see
I'm sick I don't know what's going on
with you like to sleep I can't believe
it thanks leap it was down over there
Louise I swear let's both walk away okay
good night leo
come on oh maybe we should play the rest
of the game like that Bob be the same
out God okay with that cuz I'm here I
can look in oh well that's just cheating
I didn't look into until we won and oh
girl looking wait are you I'm looking at
covering my eye okay good what me what I
don't know oh I was gonna do a clean
sweep of this right yeah just cover in
some way okay I really okay
ready here we go oh okay all right I
don't know I heard the crowd go uh-oh
yes yes you're looking
oh that is this game in a nutshell
thanks wait for being here thank you
mark thank you everybody for watching
you can watch our original table tug
down in the description or there'll be
an annotation over this one of the
funniest videos we've ever made
by far is pretty good this one not even
close no no not even we're not even
pulling out here we go so anyway thank
you again everybody for watching check
out whit's here on the description below
Lord minion 7 sometime over here
as always we'll see you in the next
video bye hey guys that's total bull
close when the show